okay what is your opinion on no this is
an open-ended one but please answer it
succinctly briefly
what's your opinion on vr
um i think vr is very interesting
um
but not for the reason people think
especially vr developers right so people
think that vr is about
uh being more immersed in a game so that
it feels
real
um and therefore it can be more
compelling or something
and nobody in the game industry seems to
want to hear this but
like there is a little bit of truth to
that that immersion i will get back to
it in a minute about what's true about
it but it's mostly false because
when you're watching a good movie you're
immersed when you're reading a good book
you're immersed when you're listening to
music that you find beautiful you're
immersed like immersion
doesn't require you to wear a bucket on
your head right that's uncomfortable and
like heavy and all these things
now
the thing the thing that it does do
that's immersive is you get a tighter
feedback loop between your
proprioceptive sense like where your
head's moving and like what you see
which is absent when you're playing like
a 3d game on a monitor because the
monitor doesn't move in response to your
head so
it it incorporates a little bit more of
your body and
this is the more important part i think
um
just the tracking on both the headset
and the controllers
um
tends to be very good these days
actually better on the controllers than
the headset
and what that means
is you have more bandwidth for
communicating to the game
right
in ways that are natural because you
know how to move your hands you know how
to move your head right and you can move
your body to move your head around to
change where you are and those are
relatively natural things compared to
you know i'm using this mouse and
keyboard or something which is not
something
that came naturally to humans before we
invented it right you can learn it in
that way that we learn to drive and
stuff but it's it's one step more
removed and so
the opportunity of vr
is
to use this added bandwidth
um
in order to create experiences
that are
um
better in some way defeat right so if
you think about if i'm playing a 3d game
with a mouse and keyboard my mouse is
like let's call that two analog degrees
of freedom it's even not that much but
whatever and then maybe the keyboard i
have like five or six keys i'm gonna hit
so it's like five or six bits
plus two
scalar numbers right
it's more like vr's advantage isn't that
it inputs something that's more
immersive to you
it's more what you output that the game
can then use that's the one that is the
most overlooked i think yes so you know
just to quantify again in
these are technically dof controllers
because there's in 3d space there's
three degrees of translation and three
of rotation so you have like 18
scalars compared to two in your mouse
and it's not actually that much because
humans don't really use them
independently but it's still it's like a
lot more right um and so
until now games
mostly talk and don't listen very much
you know like think about if you're
playing a game at 4k
at 24 bit color
at 60 frames per second
that's like a lot of bits per second
coming at you the number of bits per
second going in
is like
several orders of magnitude less than
that right like way less
so
um what can you do when you have more
we don't exactly know because i think
designers dropped the ball a little bit
in this last wave of vr i think this
last wave of vr
would have like people no usually think
oh it's because the hardware technology
isn't good enough um i do
think vr will get more successful as the
hardware gets better but
um i think designers dropped the ball
and it would have been more successful
if designers had understood
um the opportunity
and taken advantage of it
you called it a wave
meaning that we're on the lower end now
yeah it's pretty clear at this point
that
vr like okay so when
you know when palmer lucky started
oculus and then you know valve had also
been working on vr at that time and then
sony got into it and like everybody was
releasing vr systems
there was this possibility at that time
that maybe this is like the future of
all this stuff from now like it's just
gonna be this gets better and
you know i think most of the people who
bought vr systems during that time
those are like in their closet right now
or something or they're not being used
daily right that's true for me and so
um
well
what causes people to get those things
out of their closet or you know what
what's the next system that does better
that won't go into the closet quite so
fast right
are you planning on making a vr game and
or do you have ideas for vr games i have
lots of ideas for vr games um not super
super deep ones they're just more like
starting points because like i said this
process of making games is pretty hard
and you have to get really into it
and
we never really started on any of these
ideas so it's hard to say where they
would have gone but um
for sure
for sure
i see interesting places to start um for
a studio of our size we can't really
make vr games right now because we can't
afford to because if nobody buys it
i see out of business right
that might change in the future
but at this time it's just not really
something that we could do